period
[Music]
join the word inspired
sabbath august 28 at two o'clock pm
eastern standard time as denise
mccurchion hosts a q a session with
elder randy skeet on probation
other guests include
jonathan david archie kevin gomez and
stacy anne brown
questions from the live audience will
also be taken even if not directly
related to the topic
this meeting will be hosted on zoom and
live streamed to denisha mccurchion's
youtube channel personal and the word
inspired facebook pages and twitch
profile at the word inspired
links are in the description of the
video so feel free to like share and
subscribe
we hope to see you and your loved ones
there as we prepare for the coming of
our lord and savior jesus christ
thank you and god bless
happy sabbath and welcome everyone to
question and answer with elder randy
skeet on the word inspired
i'm your host denisha mccurchion and
today we are joined with special guests
elder randy skeet brother jonathan david
archie brother kevin gomez and sister
stacy ann brown
today
we are discussing probation and will be
answering questions like what is
probation and its purpose
how should we be living in this
probationary period
how do we reconcile the doctrine of
predestination with probation
stay tuned as we seek to answer these
questions
and get a closer walk with our lord and
savior
let us pray
dear heavenly father
we thank you for this opportunity to
learn of you even on your holy sabbath
day
please
forgive us of our sins
fill us with your spirit prepare our
hearts to receive your word and to live
it out in our lives
we give you all the honor the glory and
the praise and we act in a special way
that you would
rain down your spirit afresh on your
manservant elder randy skeet
put your words in his mouth oh god we
thank you for hearing and for answering
this prayer in jesus name we pray
amen
well
our speaker today
traverses the world
sharing the message of salvation
and not only has the holy spirit
prepared him
but he attended and graduated from
oakwood university and the seventh-day
adventist theological seminary at
andrews university
to do the work of the lord
let us listen be reverent and think as
he speaks please welcome
elder randy skeet
yes we can hear you now
all right i said welcome to all those
who have connected wherever you are
around this globe thank you very much
for your interest in the word of god
our subject for today is very very
important it is called probation and we
need to understand probation from the
bible's perspective
and so i pray that the spirit of god
will fill me with wisdom simple language
that those who listen may learn
[Music]
those of us speaking may also learn as
we listen one to another again i
compliment you my dear sister dr denisha
for allowing god to use you to
continually sponsor these programs i
believe they're very very enlightening
and a blessing to many many people so
god bless you and god bless all those
who are on your team so i'm ready now
for the question
amen praise this be to god and we just
thank you other skeet for coming on the
program preparing and being willing
because we know you can be many places
right now but you have taken the time to
be here with us so god bless you and
thank you
our first question
two parts
namely what is probation and the second
is what is its purpose
probation is a period of time that god
gives
to mankind or to a higher beings
to carry out his will or to conduct
themselves in a certain way
probation occurred before sin
probation occurred after sin what do i
mean by probation occurred before sin
the bible says in ii peter chapter 2
verse 4 so if god spared not the angels
of sin but cast them down to hell
this can only happen because the angels
back then were still on probation
and ellewhite makes that clear as well
in conflict and coverage page 15
paragraph three
like the angels the dwellers in eden had
been placed upon probation and so the
angelic hosts after they were made by
god were given a probationary period to
let god see whether or not they wanted
to remain faithful to him we do not know
how long that period was but god does
not accept force or robotic service and
worship he wants worship by choice
worship from love and so created beings
are given a period of probation adam and
eve were given a period of prohibition
some time in which to demonstrate that
they wanted to live god's way and so
probation is a time god gives as an act
of love and mercy in which we're
supposed to conduct ourselves in a
certain way based upon his will for us
even in the legal system there's
something called prohibition instead of
a prison term the judge may give you
probation with certain conditions you
feel you fulfill the conditions you
avoid imprisonment and so your probation
functions in the bible and in the larger
society
but probation does not last forever and
once it is closed biblically it is never
reopened let me say that again
biblically when probation is closed it
does not reopen
and the purpose of probation as i said
is for a person of
our people it could be an individual or
people to meet god's requirements to do
what god would have them to do
god is eternal yes but his patience is
not
amen i think we have to let that last
sentence sink in
god is eternal
patience
is not in prophets and kings page 276
paragraph three ella white writes god
grants to men a period of probation but
there is a point beyond which divine
patience is exhausted and the judgments
of god are sure to follow so he gives us
we see this with the antediluvians in
genesis 6 from verse 1 and it came to
pass when men began to multiply on the
face of the earth and daughters were
born unto them that the sons of god saw
the daughters of men that they were fair
and they took them wives of all which
they chose and the lord said my spirit
shall not always strive with man meaning
there are limits to my passion
for that he also is flesh yet his day
shall be 120 years and so god gave him
120 years now peter comments on this in
first peter chapter 3 reading from verse
18 for christ also hath once suffered
for sin the just for the unjust that he
might bring us to god being put to death
in the flesh but quickened by the spirit
by which also he went and preached unto
the spirits in prison meaning the
sinners in the days of noah which some
time were disobedient verse 21st peter 3
well while the the long suffering of god
waited in the days of noah while the ark
wasn't preparing so peter is telling us
that god gave them a period of time his
patience his long suffering waited for a
while as noah was building the ark but
we know when noah entered that ark and
god shut that door predation had closed
for them
amen brought the israelites
409 years
daniel chapter 9 verse 24 it is critical
to our understanding of ourselves as a
prophetic people
70 weeks are determined upon thy people
upon thy holy city and so we have that
is a it's a core part of our teaching
this 70 week prophecy which is part of
the 2 300 days it was a probationary
period which ended in 1834 when the
gospel went then largely to the gentiles
and so god gives probation because
people have to make individual choices
as to whether they'll serve god or not
adam and eve were given probation
and they failed
by the way let me say something
frightening
probation is not only a
national or corporate it is also
individual
patriots and prophets page 140 paragraph
one
every day the probation of some is
closing
every hour some are passing beyond the
reach of mercy when paul spoke to felix
in acts chapter 24 verse 25 says and as
he reasoned of righteousness and
temperance and judgment to come felix
tremblance said
he said i'll call for you some more
convenient season and ellen white writes
in patriots and prophets page four not
patriots and prophets acts of the
apostles 4 27 paragraph 2 he never
received another call from god his
probation closed because he said no to a
call of god sent by paul and so they are
individual probations in 1st samuel 16
verse 14 the spirit of god left saul
he left him
and an evil spirit troubled him so
probation closes individually probation
also closes on a larger scale because
when christ says he that is unjust let
him be unjust still that means the
closing of probation on a global scale
he no longer is a priest he's coming
back as a conquering king and so we need
to understand probation is given
globally or nationally it is also given
individually
and god never sends a text to tell you
when your probation will close all you
know you have today you have now to do
what's right in the sight of god
next question
amen well elder skeet you have actually
answered our second question which was
how does the close of probation and
noah's time informed the close of
probation at the end of time well that's
fine i'll look at that in luke 17 from
verse 26
and as it was in the days of noah so
shall it be also in the days of the
coming of the son of man dd they drank
they married wives they were given in
marriage until the day that nowhere
entered into the ark and the flood came
and took them away likewise also as it
wasn't the days of law edie they drank
they bought they sold they planted the
building but the same day a lot went out
of sodom it rained fire and brimstone
from god out of heaven and destroyed
them and so
they had a period of probation in the
days of noah they had one of the days of
love because lot went out to preach to
talk to his sons-in-law and perhaps to
others they did not listen god always
gives people an opportunity some time to
do what is right now on the individual
level probation varies god may give me
10 years he may give you 10 000. it
depends on the person's individual
circumstances but in the days of noah
there was a probationary period in the
days of love there was also one the
period for noah is mentioned as 120
years it is not mentioned for lot but we
know that lot as an agent of god
preached and called upon his sons in law
and whoever else would listen to come
out of that city and they did and so god
sends warnings he gives a certain amount
of time and then he says that's it and
he cuts you off in love because he
realizes nothing he does will change
your mind you've come to the place where
you're so set in error nothing will
change your mind or you've come to the
place where you're so set in truth
nothing the devil does can turn you from
christ one of those two conditions a
person arrives at and that probation
closes so the closest probation is not a
frightening thing unless it closes and
you are outside of god if it closes when
you're in god is the greatest news you
can find because then you cannot be lost
you understand me if you read revelation
14 well let me offer prayer again father
as i continue to speak give me wisdom i
pray in jesus name amen in revelation 14
there are two harvests
both harvests are right in other words
it's time to put in the sickle for the
harvest is right joel chapter 3 verse 13
put you in the sickle for the harvest is
right and so that's the pudding of the
sickle means probation has closed i'm
coming to the harvest but there are two
harvests in revelation 14 the harvest of
the lost and the harvest of the same
the only thing similar about them is
both harvests are ripe
one harvest is ripe against god the
other is right for god and so when jesus
declares he that is unjust let him be
unjust still revelation 22 verse 11 what
that statement means some people have
reached have come to the close of the
probation the outside of god others they
are within god so that declaration of
the clause of probation means summer out
summer in
when god closed the door of the ark
genesis 7 verse 16 some were out some
were in and the door was not open to
letting those who were out because they
had been given enough time
and so we study noah's time lots time so
we can understand how we ought to live
in this time because jesus said that's
the way it will be in his days when he
comes which are these last days
and we studied lots time and those times
that we put ourselves in the right
position regarding god let me say again
god is eternal but his patience is
limited
because he hates sin
amen amen god hates sin
but you know i really appreciate
the fact that god gives us time to make
a decision for him right that he's not a
god of coercion which is why he gives us
a period of probation now there's
something i would like to share on
noah's time as i was reading uh
you know about the time of probation
that god gave to noah those 120 years
here's what ellen white says in
manuscript
65 the year 1906 which speaks about the
individual probationary time that god
has given us
she says some of the carpenters he that
is noah employed in building the ark
believe the message but died before the
flood right
others of noah's converts backslid
many of the believing ones kept the
faith and died triumphant now that's
manuscript 35 the year 1906 the the fact
of the matter is or the the general
theme that we have to glean is as he
said elder steve
where will we be when our probation
closes that's right will we be among the
believing or will we be among the
backsliding that's right
all right i now turn it over to brother
jonathan david archie to ask the next
three
sets of questions
amen amen
and uh thank you so much elder randy ski
for
those questions in so much such detail
for all of us to understand in simple
terms and you know just piggybacking on
terms of looking at noah
not only did god use him but before noah
even began his ministry read in jude
that god had spoken through enoch
in the same prophetic message as amos
says god will never do anything in
secret he reveals
prophets so god gives his warning you
know before he brings the destruction
and so praise be to god for his mercy
and so the question to ask while we are
in this period of probation is what
should we be doing
how christians during probation and
we're going to do let's say for
christians and for the rest of the world
what should we be doing
during this probationary period
well if jesus said as it was in the days
of noah and the days of law then it
behooves us to study the days of noah
and the days of lord so we can
understand how we need to live in these
last days we ought to so live as though
today is the last day that's how the
christian ought to live because it could
be the last day
you understand you can die tonight god
forbid or i and so we live as though
this is our final day on earth or our
final hour this calls for training of
the mind to live that way but we tend to
believe i'll be alive tomorrow that's
why we procrastinate i'll be alive next
week and we make these judgments about
how long we live no your life can end
today righteous people die every day
perfectly healthy people die god may
either take you or let you pass and so
we ought to live as though today today
if you hear his voice today is the
accepted time and this is the mindset
that the people of god should have and
constantly studying the word of god to
see how close the coming of christ is
because he said if we study the science
we realize that his coming is closed
even at the door so even though we have
no precise date you know august 28 2021
but he says even at the door and that's
very very close and so we live with a
sense of imminence price is about to
come and we're constantly in the word of
god that we may more and more understand
the details of how we should live our
lives in these very very troubling and
trying times and so a sense of urgency
and a sense of emergency must
characterize the daily lives of god's
spirit but unfortunately many of us are
so wrapped up in daily living we tend to
forget that there's something above and
beyond daily living and that is securing
your place in god's eternal kingdom when
he comes if you observe
the lives in the days of lot the bible
says they didn't eat they dried they
bought they sold they planted they built
it and christ says that's the way it
will be you look at those six things
they bought they eat they dried they
bought they sold they planted they build
it none of those things is a sin they're
all just expressions of daily life but
if you just live a normal life life as
usual is poor preparation for the return
of christ let me say that again life as
usual is poor preparation for richard of
christ we must live life unusually that
is the way christ lived we must live
life unusually our priorities must be so
different our friends our colleagues our
associates begin to wonder well who are
you what's wrong with you but if we
believe we're in the last person we are
we believe probation will soon close and
it will then we cannot live life as
usual there must be something else that
becomes the priority and that is a
preparation to receive christ when he
comes a preparation to live in a world
without a high priest in the most holy
place a preparation for the trials and
tribulations much more intense that are
coming up on this world a preparation
for the time while a death penalty will
be passed to take god's commandment
people out
that's how we should be living our lives
amen amen thank you for that explanation
on and one thing i would always say is
that just as we hear jesus is the author
and the finisher
we can also say that every day jesus
must be the author of our day and the
future of our day
yes this is a revelation each day so
make sure that you do not harden your
hearts as hebrews 3 verse is 15 tells us
so the next question to ask you elder
skeet is
when does probation end
and does probation end earlier for god's
people
what happens when probation closes
no one knows when probation ends there's
no date the only the last date we had
was october 22 1844 we have no date for
the close of probation and knows why not
has available and so today is the date
for your probation personal life you say
today is the final day of my probation
because i may not see you tomorrow now
as far as um what's the second part of
the question
second part of the question was does
probation end earlier okay yes yes yes
now first peter chapter 4 verse 17 said
for the time is come that judgment must
begin at the house of god now
now that judgment does not just cover
advocates it covers all those who've
ever professed a relationship with
christ you see now he's going to judge
your profession by your works you see
you said you love me you said you've
given your life you said you were baby
you took all these baptismal vows let me
now examine how you live that's why we
saved my words we saved by faith but
we're judged by words and so this
judgment began in october 22 1844 it's a
judgment of those who have had a
relationship profess a relationship with
jesus christ so in that sense yes it
begins with the house of god i call it
the first peter 4 17. so you can say yes
it ends for adventist first because
we're all part of that group who have
professed a relationship with god now
when that judgment ends there isn't
another one
because the wicked has already condemned
themselves by rejecting christ are you
following me the wicked have already
condemned themselves by rejecting christ
so there is no need for judgment of them
as to whether they are saved or lost
they have chosen to be lost by rejecting
christ the judgment for the wicked is
the degree of punishment they'll receive
and we will join christ in doing that
during the thousand years but yes
judgment begins at the house of god and
the house of god is not just advertised
the house of god is other sheep of i
which are not of this fault them also i
must bring so it begins in the house of
god and when that judgment that
pre-advert judgment used to be called
investigative judgment ends probation
has ended there is no further judgment
to decide will be saved or who will be
lost
amen and another question that was the
finale on it was what happens when
probation closes
when probation closes what follows will
be the seven last place
christ leaves the most holy place and
he's going to come for his people but
before that they'll be they'll be
they'll be critical situation on the
face of the earth the several last space
will be poured out as an expression of
god's anger against iniquity and sin and
the world that generally i say generally
has rejected his his uh overtures of
grace his mercy his son by rejecting the
gospel in a certain sense be crucified
christ moreover and so there'll be
tremendous trials and turmoil on the
earth tremendous turmoil on the earth
and that's when god's people will be in
such such a difficult position not
because so much of the physical
condition but because they'll be
wondering am i right with god are all my
sins forgiven that will cause more
suffering for them than whatever the
wicked would be doing in trying to take
their lives so when probation closes
the several last place will be poured
out
which will cause tremendous uh chaos all
around the world in different parts of
the world not all seven hit all parts of
the world at the same time but the whole
world would be affected one area or not
with the seven plagues and gold spirit
will also suffer but not the way the
wicked will suffer
so that's what will be going on uh after
probation closes no more mercy for the
earth no more mercy that's when his
wrath is poured out without mixture into
the cup of his indignation it'll be the
very first time that god's wrath will be
poured out without a shred of mercy even
during the flood eloise tells us those
parts of the world where wickedness was
not widespread the destruction was not
that great
you see there was mercy it was not that
great but this time
god's burst god's wrath will be poured
out for the first time without mercy
and why is that because people will
accept the beast and his mark and his
image instead of accepting christ and
his seal
and that's the reason why
the wrath of god will before that total
rejection of christ because to reject
truth is to reset christ simple as that
i say it again to reject truth is to
reject christ you may keep church but
reject christ
and the wrath of god will be poured out
because people will reject christ
and they reject him by rejecting his
word and his word is condensed in his
law because the law is the all the whole
duty of man
the wrath of god on those who've
accepted the beast which is a false
system
and the mark of the beast which is a
unbiblical day of worship
and that's the reason god pours out his
wrath upon this earth
so it's essential that those listening
ask themselves
am i obeying god or am i obeying a
man-made system
there are some religious systems that a
man made
the system that saves is a system that
is god made and that's based on thus
saith the lord
by the way it's that system that says
the seventh day is the sabbath of the
lord that's the system of god
amen amen and for those that are tuning
in and probably don't even understand uh
the detail of what is october 22 1844 uh
definitely you can just go ahead and
read upon daniel
and you can read actually
going into daniel chapter let me get it
right here let's see nine yeah
you know 8 14 and 9 24 to 27. you know
it's january 14 and you can see the 2300
days on there which is 2300 years and
also highlighting upon the seven plays
which is referenced in revelation
chapter 16. that's right also we're
looking at exactly the responsibility
the duty of man which is the final
verses of ecclesiastes
thank you for those words and of course
remember probation starts at the house
of god
jesus christ all right final question
elder skeet is going to be what is the
relationship between probation and the
sealing of god's people
in uh
in that in ezekiel 9
verse 4 god tells the angel girl to the
midst of the city through the midst of
jerusalem and set the mark upon the
forces of the men that sigh and cry for
all the abominations that be done in the
midst thereof now the mystery of men in
the midst of god's people
you see god's greatest wrath is potent
against those who know and did not act
appropriately because to whom much is
given much is required one of the
greatest catastrophes in all the bible
is the destruction of jerusalem not the
destruction of babylon the destruction
of jerusalem this the suffering was
intense why because they were the ones
to whom the articles were entrusted and
they did nothing with it they
misrepresented it and misrepresented god
to the world and so
the the closer probation if i get the
question clearly
reaper so restate the question again
no problem
uh it is what is the relationship
between probation and the sealing of
god's right receiving of god is to
shield is to identify those who will not
be the targets of god's seven last place
who will not be who will be saved and
secured in god's kingdom they are sealed
in their forehead meaning the mind is
made up it is not a mark it is not some
barcode that you scan with your iphone
it is nothing of the kind it is an
intellectual a mental decision
that you will serve god regardless of
what now the mark of the beast is also
an intellectual choice and choice of the
mind to serve a man with institution and
so the sealing of god must occur before
probation closes that is the chronology
because god seals this people
then when the healing is over that's
when christ comes down and so the
ceiling first then
uh when that is finished probation
closes and so the angel was told in
ezekiel nine verse four put a mark then
god tells the angel from five six and
seven go through the city and just
destroy
destroy old and young babies beginner
the elders the priests destroy now this
is not secular babylon this is jerusalem
that god is talking about you see
because we are the light of the world so
when we mislead the world we pay a
heavier price than the world yet the
world would be destroyed yes but those
who were assigned to enlighten the world
and did not do it will pay a terrible
price and so the angel says after
sealing now go through and destroy
everyone who does not have the seal then
in revelation 7 verse 3 verse 1 after
these things i saw four angels standing
on the four corners of the earth having
before holding back the four winds of
the earth and then the angel rises from
the east having the seal of the living
god in verse two and he sets says he
sets the seal on the foreheads of god's
people there we have twelve thousand
each of the twelve tribes from verse
five to verse eight of revelation seven
and so the ceiling precedes the clause
information when the ceiling is finished
probation clauses now the judgment is
heaviness connected to that because as
our cases are examined that takes up
another program altogether several hours
those whose profession match their
lifestyle you know they've been faithful
to god what they've said you know jesus
said these people draw
they worship me with their lips but
their hearts are far from me okay there
are people who say praise the lord
praise the lord praise the lord but
their lives are something else the
judgment is to see whose life is
consistent with profession and practice
and those who meet that standard they
are sealed with the seal of god
and they're the ones who are protected
from the civilized plagues those who
don't match that they're the ones who
cut off
the ceiling precedes the close of
formation
and proceeds the falling of the seven
last place and the ceiling is going on
now
it's going on now we do not know when we
land but based on the condition of the
world it can't last much longer
amen amen and one of the things i would
love to give a simple understanding of
the sealing process if you look at this
water bottle that i'm holding if i
lay to the side the water can fall out
what you can do is you can put the cap
is the truth inside of you into the last
dimension and so we are completely
sealed and then we will see the closing
of the probation thank you very much
is there another question
amen yes elder skeet we will all right
thank you brother jonathan
amen yes thank you no problem elder
yes thank you for the jonathan for
coming on we know you preached earlier
today but we thank god that you were
able to
make it on and ask these
questions pertinent questions
question six is how do we reconcile the
doctrine of predestination
with the doctrine of probation
all right let me say immediately there
is no such thing as the doctrine of
predestination in the bible
it is a doctrine among certain churches
it is not a bible doctrine let me make
that very clear predestination is not a
bible doctrine or for ordaining or
whatever it make in other words wanting
grace always in grace or god shows you
to save and choose others to destroy
let's go to matthew
25 let me let's reason through the word
of god matthew 25
in verse 34 of matthew well i'll pray
again father in heaven as i continue let
the spirit be with me and all those
listening in jesus name i pray amen
matthew 25
the parable of the sheep and the goats
in verse 3 now the shepherd sets the
sheep on the right hand and the goats on
the left
in verse 34 then shall the king say unto
them on his right hand
come me blessed of my father
inherit the kingdom prepared for you
from the foundation of the world
what he tells the wicked in verse 40 and
is departs from e curse into everlasting
fire prepared for the devil and his
angels now let's reason
jesus said matthew 25 40 and 41
hell was prepared for the devil and his
angels human beings are not mentioned
which means we can argue that god has
always determined that all human beings
would be saved now when you use the word
determined it doesn't mean he decided
they'll be saved contrary to what they
want are you following me it is god has
chosen his will is he would love to
serve serve everybody so in that sense
there's a
predestination if you want to call it
that i don't like that term at all
the bible says in a second peter chapter
3 verse 9 he god is not willing that any
should perish in first timothy chapter 2
verse 4 who will have all men to be
saved and to come unto the knowledge of
the truth and so the bible teaches
clearly god's will his desire let me
repeat his will is that all people will
be saved so he has chosen us
to save us but we exercise our own minds
and so you read ii peter chapter two
from verse four for if god spared not
the angels that sinned they chose to sin
and verse 5 and spared not the old world
but save noah the eighth person a
preacher of righteousness bringing in
the flood upon the world of the ungodly
so we go from the angels who fell to
those in the days of noah to those in
days of lots
and peter goes through the history and
then he tells us they have forsaken the
right way and gone astray verse 15 of
second peter chapter two and so god's
god's choice his will is that everyone
would be saved god has not chosen to
save some and destroy others he doesn't
do that
god john 3 16 for god soul of the world
the world what does the world mean
everybody that he gave his only begotten
whosoever son
does whosoever
mean anyone who chooses to believe and
so predestination is not a doctrine in
in the bible god doesn't choose to serve
to save some and choose to destroy some
people destroy themselves by their
choices
so god's desire is to save everyone
but he allows us to express our choices
when god made adam and eve he did not
make them to fall he made them to live
in a condition in which he made them
they chose to sin
and when contrary to god's will for them
jesus could have chosen to sin but thank
god he did not make that choice
we we must live our lives with the
understanding that god wants to save you
doctor alicia mccrichen he wants to save
jonathan he wants to see if whoever's
listening god wants to save you that's
his original will now will you cooperate
with that will that's the point you see
we do not cooperate with god's original
choice he has chosen you for christmas
kingdom and so the bible says hell was
prepared for the devil and his angels
not for human beings that tells us
clearly god originally chose all human
beings for salvation but they made the
individual choice to go against god and
some will be lost and so jesus prayed in
john 17 12
those that now gave us me i have kept
and none of them is lost but the son of
perdition meaning judas judas was lost
so one save always saved is not a bible
teaching at all
predestination is not a bible doctrine
god does not predestine some of the
salvation and predestined for damnation
no he wants to save everybody
but some of us choose not to be saved
you know you read ezekiel 33 verse 11
say unto them as i live saith the lord i
have no pleasure in the wicked but that
the wicked turn from his way and live
turn me turn me from your evil ways for
why will he die says god why are you so
determined to die while i'm so
determined to save you but i cannot
force salvation on you why says god will
you die
i want you saved why are you dying
people choose death
uh proverbs 8 36 all day that hate me
love death
and in that chapter wisdom is
personified wisdom they means christ all
they that hate kneel of death
john 3 19 and this is the condemnation
that light is coming to the world and
men love darkness rather than light they
love darkness rather than light that's
the problem god has chosen everyone for
salvation
but we do not cooperate with his choice
with his will and consequently many will
be lost but there is no such teaching in
the bible as predestination in the sense
that god has chosen john for salvation
and jack for damnation that is not a
biblical teaching at all
nor is the teaching once safe always
saved that is not biblical
amen amen elder skeet and i i just want
to just want to read ephesians chapter 2
verse 10. here's what the bible says for
we are his that's god's work
created in christ jesus unto good works
which god hath ordained and he should
walk in them right jesus christ died for
everyone so god has ordained all of us
he's given us all the opportunity to put
out the life of christ
even if we were to look at romans romans
chapter 8 i know we we love verse 28
where it says
all things work together
amen amen
and we know that all things work
together for good to them that believe
god and to them who are the called
according to his purpose verse 29 here's
where we get a little trouble where it
says for whom he did for no he did
predestin
predestinate to be conformed to the
image of his son
that he might be the first born among
many but the question is who did god
foreknow
every single one of us every single one
of us
is performed exactly and to all of us he
gives the opportunity to accept jesus
christ as our lord and savior and this
is how we can begin to marry the
questions that have been asked because
in the beginning we asked what is the
purpose of probation why do we have
probation what is it it's because god
wants to give us a choice to serve him
he wants to give us the choice the
question is that you said aldusky will
we cooperate with god's will
and we don't
all right so let us look at the next
question the final question
first season question seven
what tips can we use to break the spirit
of procrastination
and prepare for christ during this
probationary period
we can live our lives the way look at
the rhythm of god's operation when he
created
genesis chapter 1 verse 5 and the
evening in the morning with the first
day
look at verse 8 even in the morning with
the second day you look at the god
function one day at a time are you
following me that's the way we ought to
live because we do not know anything
about tomorrow we should live one day at
a time we should live with a sense of
urgency a sense of purpose a sense of
god's desire for us that's how we ought
to live one day at a time we ought to
live with our minds our hearts in the
word of god because the word is a lamp
into our feet a light onto our path we
shall make choices in the light of the
fact we're living in the last days now
there might have been a different
attitude there's abraham because abraham
was thousands of years removed from the
close of probation on a global scale he
was thousands of years removed from
october 23 1844 even paul was but we are
literally
on the doorstep of return of jesus
christ and so our lives ought to reflect
a sense of urgency that perhaps has
never been seen before and that urgency
means we need to ask what is really
important
and the important thing that should
stand before everyone's eye is a
preparation to receive christ even if my
i close my eyes in death today am i
ready to receive my savior and this is
the way we ought to live we ought to
stay in god's word we ought to stay in
the testimonies of ellen white that
special instructions sent to god's
people and we ought to do what we can to
enlighten others so that our whole life
suggests that we're focusing on the
return of christ and a preparation to
meet our savior when he comes
amen amen one day at a time
i was reading councils to parents
teachers and students a while back
by ellen white and she was talking about
a man that was very productive and
everybody wondered how did he get
everything done and he told them simple
i do one thing at a time
i do one thing at a time and it's crazy
because even at my school
we have uh sessions on how we should
study and how we can you know put in our
hours and there is a technique called
the pomodoro technique what is it you
take 25 minutes of focused time where
you accomplish one task so you work on
one task and then you take some time to
take a break taking one day at a time
one task at a time one at the time
so then we're not worried about what the
next step will be because we are present
with jesus uh the miracle of turning
water to wine when the mother said they
have no wine christ said woman what if i
to do with thee my hour is not yet come
in other words is not the time for this
it's time for something else now in john
17 he says father the hour is come and
so christ lived is like this is a time
for that this is the time for that
and he did not do things out of time
you see he did not otherwise said he
woke up every day and asked god what
should he do he was that close to his
father and we ought to try to be that
close to god and so
living in the moment as you said today
is all i have
this hour is all i have what can i do to
get closer to my savior because you
cannot get too close to god
amen amen
lucifer was close to god and look at
what happened to him
you can't get in close to god and
lucifer and he fell
mystery of mysteries and mysteries of
negativity so we need to keep clinging
clinging clinging with a consciousness
to our savior
amen amen
thank you elder skeet
now we have some questions from last
month
okay um
i know we had kind of touched on it but
sister and laurie asked what happened on
1888 in reference to the general
conference
and how is it connected to our time
from october 17 to november 4 i believe
was this very famous general conference
session in minneapolis not too far well
in the midwest you know where that is
and um
it is well known for the teaching of
wagner and jones righteousness by faith
it also is known for some controversy
prior to the conference there was a
bible institute a bible class that ran
for about seven and a half days from the
10th to the 17th and there was some
heated argument about
you know the horns
of daniel 7 what nations actually are
represented by the horns and it was an
argument between jones and uriah smith
uh swift was a recognized expert on
prophecy anyway so that preceded the
actual general conference when the
conference began the controversy then
became righteousness by faith taught by
jones and wagner and
after the conference people look back
and they wrote books and they summarized
and they
some said well the church accepted the
truth others said the church rejected it
uh so we you'll have this back and forth
eloise writes very obviously about the
fact that the truth was not fully
accepted and i had the church taking the
message and everyone had done what he or
she should have done the whole message
would have gone to the whole world she
makes that very very clear
um
we look back on that now i mean i need
to ask ourselves
what is our condition today
are we
leo decean
in verity or do we learn from our past
we learn from our past rejection of
truth as some believe occurred in 1888
can we accept the truth that el white
said god gave to these two men
now while what the men said is not
exactly written down but we can glean
what they teach from what ellen white
wrote in the books after 88 steps to
christ desire they jesus christ object
lessons thoughts about the blessing and
ministry of healing those five books she
wrote after the eight immediate session
and you could see what was taught by
what she wrote because what she writes
is far more authoritative than what
jones and wagner said even though she
said they had credentials from god but
they were not prophets as she was
and so we need to make sure that we are
in harmony with the truth as god has
laid it out clearly in his word and made
it very very clear in the writings of
his servant evan white and i urge
everyone listening to me to make a
decision to read steps to christ
microscopically re desire of ages reach
christ's object lessons thoughts on the
amount of blessing at least those four
books of course ministry of healing but
the first four especially steps to
christ i believe that came first
then desire of ages then i think christ
subject lessons thoughts amount of
blessing read those four books if you
want to understand uh
righteousness by faith justification by
faith obedience through faith
so we need to measure ourselves
are we consistent with the plainly
spoken word of god as he is laid out in
his word and made very clear to us
almost with kindergarten simplicity in
the writing as well and why and i urge
you again all those listening read steps
to christ microscopically
read it along with the bible passages on
which it deals and also the desire of
ages
amen see people don't change people
don't change because truth is truth and
the carnal nature is the carnal nature
the carnal nature is what it is from
adam until now truth is what it is from
god until now the carnal nature does not
like truth it has no problem with church
it has a problem with truth and so we
need to make sure that we're in harmony
with truth and the central teaching of
the bible is justification by faith what
god does for you and in you
he does for you when he justifies you he
does in you with your cooperation when
you live a righteous life day today
which is called sanctification the
central teaching of the bible is
justification or righteousness by faith
amen amen thank you all the skeet
righteousness by faith yes because no
person can save himself or herself no
matter who you are you cannot save
yourself if that were the case calvary
was a waste of time waste of blood you
cannot save yourself you can have 10
phds in theology you cannot save
yourself you can be a direct descendant
of enoch and elijah and moses who live
in heaven right now you cannot save
yourself you may have wings you cannot
save yourself and so there's something
christ must do for you and in you but on
both of those for you and in you
requires your cooperation
amen
and one thing i would like to be found
rejecting truth let us not be found
rejecting truth the seven days the
sabbath that's biblical and there's
nothing in the bible that changes that
there's nothing outside that changes
what the bible says the seventh day is
the sabbath
i like to harp on that because it's the
key issue
and accept it the seventh day is the
sabbath
jesus is fully divine
accept that if he is less than divine he
cannot save you
because only god can save from sin so
jesus must be defined
any being less than god cannot save you
only god can save you and so and i don't
want to go on and on and on but
matthew 1 21 thou shalt call his name
jesus he shall save his people from
these sins matthew 1 23 call him emanuel
meaning god with us only god can save
don't reject that truth don't make
christ less than god he is fully divine
and don't make the holy spirit less than
divine because he is that convicts you
of sin and the bible is clear you you
you blaspheme christ there is
forgiveness you bless your holy spirit
there's none so you've got to
align yourself with these fundamental
bible truths you're saved by christ who
is fully divine you're convicted by the
spirit that's fully divine
you're accepted in the beloved by god
the father of course was fully divine
and that the seventh day is the sabbath
of the lord thy god and the pope cannot
change it your iman cannot change it
your prophet cannot change it your
whomever cannot change it
the city accept the truth the better it
is for you and those around you
you need to carry on like that but
i said it there it is
amen next question
sister cassandra james has asked
reading isaiah 57 verse 1 she sees that
god will put many to sleep for the time
of trouble yes
if a person died and was not assured of
where they stand with god even though
they have accepted him can such a person
rise up in the resurrection
a person
a person who accepts christ will have
this certainty of salvation
because to accept christ it's accept
salvation
christ is salvation are you following me
yes you're not accepting a doctrine
you're accepting a person
the doctrine talks about the person
there are people with phds and theology
who don't follow christ but they can
explain the bible to you
to accept christ is to accept salvation
so he or she who has accepted christ
truly has accepted salvation and the
assurance of your salvation lies in the
person you accepted not in what you do
but in the person you have accepted your
assurance of salvation is in jesus
christ he's our wisdom our righteousness
our sanctification our redemption first
corinthians 1 verse 13 verse 30 so to
accept christ is to accept salvation
christ complained in john 5 40 he will
not come to me that he might have life
god has given to us eternal life this
life is in his son first john 5 11. so
if a person truly accepts christ the
person has accept and the presence of
christ in you gives you that assurance
you can't build that assurance the
presence of christ in you gives you that
assurance so if someone dies not sure he
or she is saved the question has to be
asked did the person truly accept christ
or the person simply accept the doctrine
you don't save my doctrines you're saved
by a person let me stress that again a
person
the doctrine simply tells us about him
but he himself
is salvation
so if you accept christ
you give your life to him you believe
without being able to explain how he
dwells within you then his presence in
you creates the assurance of salvation
you cannot manufacture that assurance it
becomes arrogance and pride he is the
assurance
amen you know i i don't want to belabor
the point but i'm just thinking about
exodus chapter 33 and then going into
chapter 34 where moses is like lord
how do i know that you are going to be
with me to lead the people to the
promised land
give me a sign show me your glory and
what did god do god proclaimed his name
to moses
he he in fact the bible says and the
lord descended in the cloud and stood
within there his presence his presence
his indwelling presence is the assurance
his assurance is a person
i don't mean
assurance is a person salvation is a
person
conversion is a person it is all in
christ
and when he's in you like alcohol he
changes the way you walk the way you
think when you see the way you speak he
changes everything if he is in you
not just in the bible in you
he works from the inside out
amen let this mind be in you which was
also
christ jesus
okay
all right sister cheryl pierre has asked
is it possible to have missed your
opportunity to be sealed
well
yes of course
of course it is possible that's why it's
so dangerous to play with jesus
is dangerous you know people they
receive convictions from god all the
time
they know it but they resist it
they won't come to church they won't
study they want they feel the conviction
they know that they ought to make this
change make that they don't do it and
the time comes where they have lost all
opportunity to come to christ
yes you can lose the opportunity to be
sealed and to be sure about jesus christ
you can lose that opportunity but god
gives us long opportunity many extended
he's long suffering but at some point
you can lose it yes you can
and you lose all spiritual things all
interest
and not even the holy spirit then can do
anything with you because you're gone
you know you look at the plagues in
chapter 16 of revelation god sends the
plague the people still blasting him
you see what i'm saying they are so set
against him instead of saying no no i'm
sorry i'm sorry they blasphemed him as
the plagues fall they continue to
blaspheme him
they're dead set against you so you and
i well you and i hopefully not but
someone can come to the place where he
or she has missed
that final opportunity to be right with
christ it's a tragedy because you cannot
reverse that
you're people running around every day
playing with eternal life
my thinking i have tomorrow i have the
day after half next week i have 2022.
you don't
you have today
today mm-hmm
all right
question let me say
someone sent me a question on on twitter
is it okay to take a small glass of wine
i just smiled we deal with probation now
you see the things that overthrow most
people are not big they're small the
kingdom of heaven is like a mustard seed
but the kingdom of satan is also like
the mustard seed you take that one
little seed into you you can destroy
your entire life so i wrote back and
said a little glass of wine okay all
adam did was to take a little glass of
fruit that's all he did and look what
happened to the world and so the person
wrote back and said oh man well i need
to avoid it i said yes and so the little
things we ought to watch the big things
they're so obvious the little things we
ought to watch very closely because adam
and eve fell on what we may regard as a
little thing
so in this troubled style you have to
watch the little things in our lives
all right up to the nation next question
amen
next question the next question comes
from motorola 1 5g ace all right in the
new earth made new will we be living in
houses being made by man
let's pray again father in heaven as we
continue continues the grandest wisdom
all of us i pray in jesus name amen
john 14 1-3 let not your heart be
troubled do you believe in god believe
also in me in my father's house are many
mansions if you were not so i would have
told you i go to prepare a place for you
christ is god we know there's a city
that's coming down from heaven you know
there's a space station up in the up in
the sky somewhere people have lived
there for years there now god can build
a city in space it's coming down and
god's been released in that city will
also live in the countryside so yes
there'll be little houses have what they
will look like we don't know but
there'll be literal houses you live in
life in the new world is not as kind of
a floating around like disembodied
ghosts that's not what it is it is a
literal
three-dimensional existence even christ
will be three-dimensional he will always
keep his human form and since you have
human form you need a three-dimensional
world in order to function and have
meaning and so yes life will there will
be houses you'll plant your vineyards
the bible says you you eat from them
we'll have things to do we don't know
all the details but it will be a life
the major difference is or the major
difference is
we see god face to face and there is no
sin
there is no sin but as verily as heaven
is a busy place where angels have the
responsibilities and they're traveling
back and forth we will have our duties
in the new world so yes there'll be a
real life
but the details have been hidden from us
most of them
get there that's the important thing
and whatever happens there you'll like
it
amen
all right our next question comes from
brother jonathan
and he asks for you to explain ephesians
chapter 1 verses 4 and 5.
visions one before
that i can read it here okay aloud
the word of the lord says and father
please guide us now in jesus name
amen
in fact i'll read from verse three
because that's where the sentence starts
okay blessed be the god and father of
our lord jesus christ
who hath blessed us with all spiritual
blessings in heavenly places ah there's
a devotional guide called in heavenly
places
in heavenly places in christ
according as he had chosen us
in him before the foundation of the
world that we should be holy and without
blame before him in love this is verse 5
having predestinated us unto the
adoption of children by jesus christ
to himself according to the good
pleasure of his will
and verse 6
the praise of the glory of his grace
wherein he hath made us accepted in the
beloved yes now that does not teach
predestination as the world understands
it it simply says what we said earlier
god has in god has chosen us in christ
for salvation he has chosen us in christ
to reflect the character of christ we
are accepted in the beloved it is god's
will that every single person
be saved it can only be done through
christ and so ephesians 1 4 7
that passage does not teach
predestination the sense god chooses
some for salvation and some for
damnation because this same price in
whom we're
we're connected to god he died for the
whole world we've got to study the bible
here a little there little john 3 16 he
died for the whole world and so we're
chosen in christ unto god
so that we might be accepted in the
beloved this was god's will for his
creation
of course we know mankind shows
differently
god's
will for us
is that when he saved
he decided that even before we were born
he decided that there was this
everlasting covenant between the father
and the son even for adam and eve were
made
if
sin occurred this and this would happen
so god made preparations long time
because he wanted to save all
but that passage does not teach
god saves some
and
destroys others by some preordained
standard
god's desire is to save everyone in
christ
so his his will
as you read in ephesians 2 which god
hath before ordained that we should walk
them god's will is that we walk like
jesus christ we live like jesus christ
all of that was his original will yes
but our choices created problems
because god cannot force salvation on
anyone
because if he could he would have saved
lucifer
but he didn't because this was
determined to be lost god cannot
salvation is not forced destruction is
not forced both are chosen
amen amen well elder skeet the time is
now 301 all right i i i'm not gonna
proceed to ask any other questions
unless it's okay with you that's fine
that's fine that's fine
what's the question
all right thank you so brother john
o'labby has asked three questions i'll
i'll probably just take one out of them
okay others can have a chance
how many times would man be sealed
before probation i think this is in
reference to if someone were to fall
away from the truth someone was in the
truth would they be sealed then and then
they fall away and then they come back
are they sealed again
someone sealed in the context of
revelation 7
and revelation 14 will not fall away
you're following me someone on whom the
scene is placed
the the the the the investigative
judgment is going on when a seal is
placed on a person that person won't
fall away
are you following me from christ the
person is sealed that's the purpose of a
seal you are sealed you set you know
it's a signed seal delivered as that
common the saying goes you're sealed you
won't fall away from christ
can you make a mistake yes that's not
falling away from jesus christ you will
not fall away from christ so when the
when the decrees goes forth he that is
unjust let him be unjust still he that
is holy let him be holy still there is
no falling away for the holy person and
there's no coming to christ for the
unholy person when you're sealed you
seal that's it that's why you seal them
here in your forehead you've made up
your mind and nothing can change you
from that
hey man reminds you the song i've got my
mind made
all right
all right so let me not sing today all
right sister a sister alana kawashi has
asked
looking at daniel 2 and the statue that
is spoken about there how can you apply
this to the topic
of probation
how can you apply to the topic of
addition well i don't know
how we can apply it i can tell you this
that
statue
which uh
god gave
to the nebuchadnezzar division
it i guess it has probation in it
because
daniel told nebuchadnezzar in daniel 2
verse 37 thou art the side of gold
and after thee shall rise another
kingdom inferior to thee and another
third kingdom of brass so we have
probation babylon would run for a
certain period of time and that would be
it same for me the person for greece for
rome and so we have the concept of
probationary time within that image
that god gave in a dream or vision to
nebuchadnezzar yes nothing lasts forever
except eternal life
amen so they had probationary periods to
do the lord's will
because even secular nations are
required to do god's will as they know
it
nebuchadnezzar did not
of course he'll be saved but largely he
did not
the media persians did not the greeks
did not the romans did not even though
god rules in the affairs of men
the one group that god relied on
consistently were the israelites that
they consistently failed it and so in
that image we see the concept of
probation babylon would not last forever
or any of the other kingdoms
nor the ten that make up the toes by the
way
but that kingdom that will be settled in
the time of the torah it will last
forever
only the things of god should last
amen and i'm thinking uh to daniel
chapter seven where is the verse
verses 11 and 12.
their lives were prolonged for a season
and a time that's right
amen now i see yes i see that dr jules
you have raised your hand um and this is
global if any of you have a question you
would like to ask directly to other
students
use the raise your hand feature will
unmute you and you can ask your question
so i will
ask you to unmute and dr jules you can
pose your question
um good afternoon everyone good
afternoon elder skate
yes
how are you doing um
is that abraham jewels
you know i i
i almost thought it was but here in the
philippines i don't think this is not
abraham oh okay okay okay okay no it's
not right oh no um i've been trying to
get your contact for abram is my good
friend i've been trying to get your
contacts for a while really i want
to yeah i'm a minister
i've been trying to have um
a study with you as well
um
dr jules i really do not i'm sorry to
interrupt but is it okay if we proceed
with the rest of the questions
and you know afterwards you can
coordinate with elder skeet in terms of
contact dr denise just give dr jules my
email please that'll be fine thank you
doctor
thank you thank you all right so
the next question comes from
ryan
the question is what happens to a person
when they fully give their hearts to
christ
and truly repent
yeah what does that person go through
all right let's pray father in heaven
continue to speak through us all of us
give us truth give us light i pray in
jesus name amen what happens to a person
when the person gives the life entirely
to christ the life of christ begins to
be expressed in that person galatians 2
20. paul says i am crucified with
christ's meaning he has died to his past
life as christ died and he has risen
with christ romans 6 4-6 he has he died
with christ he rose with christ if we
are planted in the likeness of his death
we shall be also in the likeness of his
resurrection romans 6 5 so the person
who's given the life to christ has died
with christ and rises with christ to
walk in newness of life first john 2 6
we should walk even as he walked and so
the person who's given the life to
christ will begin to live the life of
christ if that surrender is truly
complete and it is renewed daily it must
be renewed daily so a surrendered life
becomes
the vehicle to which christ expresses
his life
to that person
i am crucified with christ nevertheless
i live yet not i but christ liveth in me
that's the experience of a person who
has truly given the life to christ and
does that daily
the person loves the things of christ
spiritual things becomes his or her
priority and the person can say like job
i have esteemed the words of his mouth
more than my necessary food the person
can stay like jesus himself i have need
to eat you know
the person said like jeremiah thy words
were found and i did eat them the person
is saying like david oh how lovely thy
law it is my meditation all the day
that's the change that comes over that
person spiritual things become the
person's priority
amen amen
amen
all right elder skeet persons are saying
thank you in the chat for answering your
question for answering their questions
um this next one comes to andrew chin
which is how would you go about
converting a muslim
all people are converted the same way in
the sense that it is the spirit of god
there isn't a conversion style for
muslim one for baptist one for atheists
it is the truth the convicting truth
apply to the person's heart by the
spirit of god that's how all people are
converted now you may adopt your
approach you understand your approach
but the truth of god everyone said the
truth affects all nationalities and by
extension all religions the same way the
truth spoken and the truth lived the
combination of truth spoken and truth
lived on the right time because jesus
said in john 16 12 i have yet many
things to say unto you but you cannot
bear them now it's not enough to speak
the truth we must speak at the right
time and so the conversion of a muslim
or hindu or whomever requires the spirit
of god working on that person through
the simple word of truth
spoken at the right time and the spirit
will lead you to the right time but all
people are converted by the spirit of
god
applying the word to the person's heart
and life
so you ask god what's the right time
i let god open the way for you and he'll
do that because he's not willing that
any should perish those who do bible
work must always keep this verse in
their mind second peter 3 verse 9 the
lord is not willing that any should
perish they should also keep in mind
first timothy chapter 2 verse 4 who will
have all men to be saved and to come to
the knowledge of the truth so if your
bible's uh worker remember this it is
god's will that people come to the
knowledge of the truth keep this in mind
as you do your work very very noble work
as a bible worker or preacher or teacher
whatever your line of work may be
amen amen we must we must pray that god
give us a burden for souls
and you see that's the problem we don't
have a burden for souls we just don't we
don't
we don't have a burden for souls we must
ask
because the carnal nature will never
manufacture a burden for souls we must
ask
god put upon me a love for souls
and he'll do that
amen amen but the love is not
accompanied by a knowledge of god's word
so you do not mislead the soul
that too
amen interestingly enough elder skeet um
one of the questions that was asked last
week um tied into the one that was just
axed which is there are many um muslims
and other denominations who say jesus
gave them a dream
they how come they're always going to
the sunday keeping church this is from
atma why can't god just show them his
sabbath
god shows people things at different
times
again i go back to john 16 12. i have
yet many things to say until you cannot
bear them now god knows the right time
to show people the sabbath truth or some
other truth you present truth the wrong
time you risk having it rejected and so
god knows when to present what and so if
a person is truly touched by the spirit
of god
god will reveal truth at the right time
to that person so don't worry about they
went to sunday church
let the person continue to remain open
to the revelations of god's spirit and
god will lead the person in his or her
good time all people are not converted
the same way under the same
circumstances
but if the person is genuinely seeking
truth
he or she will find it because john 7 17
says if any man will do his will he
shall know the doctrine so a willingness
to obey truth is essential to understand
the truth
amen amen
all right um let's move on to the next
question
okay this is from sarah kim's
she says hello pastor
the anvil evangelicals teach that the
sabbath day was a sign for the
scientific covenant just as circumcision
was for the abrahamic covenant
therefore the sabbath is not binding
today since we have rest in jesus as
it's indicated in hebrews 4.
they also refer to
2 verses 16 and 17 to claim
the seventh day sabbath is not fighting
today
so i guess he's asking how would you
address this
i
can't tell how many times i've run
across this
colossians 2 16 and 17 that
he rules forward there's rest in jesus
yes there's rest in jesus it is rest
from sin okay
let's look at the sabbath as given to
the jews
the sabbath was given to the jews
entrusted to the jews to be given to the
whole world but we are getting ahead of
ourselves the sabbath was introduced to
adam and eve
are you with me
to adam and eve genesis 2 from verse 1
thus the heavens and the earth were
finished and all the hosts of them and
the seventh day god ended his work which
he had made in two and three of genesis
chapter two now when god presented the
sabbath to adam and eve they were the
population of the world there were no
jews
the population of the world was two
we don't need eight billion people to
have a population there's a population
of two and they were to replenish the
earth the sabbath was given to the world
jesus is very clear jesus was a jew but
here's what he said the sabbath was made
for man that's what jesus said not man
so christ himself who was a jew
the finest jew you can find was jesus
he said the sabbath was made for man now
if you li if you read the fourth
commandment i'll go through it exodus
28-11 remember the sabbath day to keep
it holy six days shall thou labor and do
all thy work but the seventh day is the
sabbath of the lord thy god in it thou
shalt not do any work now listen to who
should not work thou not my son that i
daughter a man's servant or a
maidservant not a cattle nor thy
stranger that is within thy gates now
the stranger also had to be aware of
sabbath keeping
but
circumcision the stranger could not take
part in circumcision if you're in exodus
12 he could not take part in
circumcision it was reserved only for
for for jew deacon sorry he could not
take part in the uh the passover feast
it was only reserved for circumcised
jews
but
the sabbath was for everyone circumcised
or not you see the stranger was not a
circumcised person
so he could not take part in the
passover feast exodus 12 from 44 onward
but if he was in an area where they were
jews and living in the territory he had
to respect the south and so the sabbath
then was universal
passover was restricted
the sabbath is universal and so the
sabbath is not for the jews the sabbath
is for mankind
and this business of
colossians 2 14-16
nails at the cross now what was nails at
the cross were the ceremonial laws if
you go to leviticus 23
in that chapter all seven annual feasts
are listed in leviticus 23
in the order in which they fall
passover
feast of 11 bread
the feast of first fruits feast of weeks
which the new testament calls pentecost
the feast of trumpets day of atonement
feast of tabernacles those are the seven
feasts
you had four in the spring three in the
fall and they all taught the entire plan
of salvation from coming to christ
passover until you land in heaven feast
of tabernacles
now
in that chapter before god gives the
first one which is passover beginning in
verse 5 he mentions the sabbath in verse
which means he sets it aside
and then he says verse 4 these are the
feasts of the lord even the holy
convocations which he shall proclaim in
this season now the sabbath has no
season so long before you get to
colossians you don't even have to get to
colossians you look at the you look at
the earlier parts of the scripture which
provide guidance the sabbath has no
season
on the other seven feasts not other
feasts the sabbath is not a feast the
seven feasts they had caesar's look at
verse five of leviticus 23 in the 14th
day of the fifth month at even is the
lord's passover now the 14th day can
fall on any day of the week like your
birthday does and my birthday does that
is not the case with the sabbath it is
not seasonal
and so while the seven feasts represent
the entire span of salvation the sabbath
is set aside because it is not a feast
it is not a ceremonial event it is
central to the life of the saved person
when christ died all the seven feasts
ceased
the sabbath did not cease that's why
jesus said when you're running in the
time of trouble he told his listeners
when jerusalem will be destroyed make
sure that your flight be not on the
sabbath day and that occurred 40 years
after he died he expected them to be
keeping the sabbath and so to say that
when christ died on the cross he he
crucified the sabbath how then could he
tell people 40 years later be sure your
flight is not on the sabbath day
when we study the bible we must not
bring our cherished opinions to the
bible we must come with an open mind and
let the bible teach us
there's a fundamental opposition in
people
to one of the ten commandments a
fundamental opposition and that
opposition is the sabbath commandment
that's why it'll be the test commandment
when the israelites came out of egypt in
exodus chapter 16 god tested them to see
if they would obey him generally by
testing them on the fourth commandment
the seventh commandment by sending manna
six days of the week and not on the
seventh and that commandment remains the
test commandment today it is the sign
between people and their god not just
the jews between anyone who keeps the
sabbath and god and so the sabbath is
not the ceremonial feast it was
separated from the seven in leviticus 23
read verse three and then the seventies
begin in verse five the sabbath is a
part of god's commandments it is no more
ceremonial than thou shalt not kill that
is not ceremonial he still exists today
and required by god that we keep it all
10.
amen amen now elder skeet i will ask the
last two questions all right um and the
third one which is not you know directly
related to this topic the next question
comes from rodney smith this was from
last month it is 5 30 7 8 on bc it's
given as the time where the children of
israel were freed of babylonian
captivity
this person is asking what is the exact
start date of the 70 years prophecy
spoken of by jeremiah
well daniel 9 24 says 70 years are
determined upon by people the hebrew
word determines cut off set apart it it
is cut off from the from the 23 from the
from the 2300 day prophecy which was
given in the previous uh chapter except
of 8 of daniel which daniel could not
understand is the only period prior to
daniel 9 24 period of time
now it began in 457 bc you see there
were three decrees issued when cyrus
took over from the babylonians in ezra
chapter chapter one verse one onward
cyrus this is a decree that the jews can
go back in uh chapter six darius takes
over he issues a decree that you know
the temple could be rebuilt then in
chapter eight i believe another decree
under artaxerxes so we have a decree
under osiris we have one of the darius
one on the other xerxes the one on the
artix xerxes was given in 457 bc it was
the most comprehensive which allowed the
jews to reestablish themselves as a
religion to follow their laws and have
the law read to them it was the most
comprehensive of the three and it was
given issued in 457 bc in the fall of
that year that's where we did so the
bible says from the going forth of the
decree to restore and to build jerusalem
and to messiah the prince shall be seven
weeks and three score in two weeks so
457 is the starting date for the 2300
day prophecy it is not connected to when
the jews will physically release under
cyrus in a five cyrus conquered i think
babylon 538-537
but the beginning the 2300-day prophecy
is 457 that is conclusively demonstrated
by a careful study of the
bible amen thank you and it ended in
october 22 1844 in the fall very precise
amen amen uh final question related to
the topic this is from pastor garnett
morris he's uh the pastor of the
cornerstone seventh-day adventist church
right here in brooklyn i reckon that
name
yes you recognize that name god bless
amen amen so dr garnett eldeski gives
you the blessing to praise the blessings
of god on you that's right his question
is yeah the fallout from covent 19 and
all the strict the fallout oh yes yes
the fallout from covet 19 and all the
restrictions compulsory act to take the
shot etc
does that give us a marker as to where
we are in this probationary time if so
how and where are we in time
i can't find a bible text that
identifies covet 19 but i i i tend to
agree with the pastor although he's
asking questions not making a statement
it certainly is an opportunity for us to
take a closer look at the times in which
we live because as we look at
restrictions that are being placed and
the restrictions are spreading wider and
wider
a friend of mine wrote me from the
philippines in order to fly from one
town to another
she must present a negative test
i was in belize preaching
and to come back to the us i had to get
a test which was negative
when i landed there i had to take a test
which was negative so it is spreading
further and for these restrictions now
that um the fisa i think vaccine has
been approved by the cdc and uh i'm not
a scientist by any means not a doctor
there's the feeling that these
restrictions will be spread even wider
the entire military now is targeted you
must take the vaccine
and so it gives us an opportunity to
step back and look you see when god does
something on the earth or allows it he
does it or allows it in connection with
the great controversy adventists we have
this this advantage this viewpoint
everything god does allows is somehow
connected to the great controversy which
is coming to an end and god's agent on
the earth for the carrying out of that
controversy
is the church so there's nothing god
does on the earth that is not somehow
connected to the church and so the
church needs to step back and ask the
question what is god trying to tell us
not fighting each other declaring some
to have the mark of the beast who take
the vaccine or those who don't take it
opposing the government whatever the
case may be we as a church should step
back and say what is god trying to tell
us what is god trying to show us about
ourselves is he trying to open our eyes
to the imminence of his return and so
yes i believe it is an opportunity for
us to look closely to get into god's
word and to see
because some of us have a veil of our
eyes for us to see that we are truly
truly close to time when we will see the
final events as mentioned in matthew 24
luke 21 and luke and mark 13. so yes i
believe this coveted crisis which is
global
is a prelude and i'm saying i believe
that it's a prelude to worse that is to
come on this earth and we should take
this opportunity first
to look at our relationship with god
to understand what does god absolutely
require of me in this world if the
government says right
do i go right or do i go left what do i
do and upon what standard do i make that
choice and that standard is the ten
commandments this is the whole duty of
man
so the crisis of covet 19 should be
viewed as an opportunity by the church
to look at itself more closely
corporately and for individual members
to re-examine the relationship with god
because as things are going we can see
more and more restrictions which means
that the beast power which controls the
secular powers and will exert more
control is doing its work in some way we
may not fully understand but i believe
let me say it again that this crisis is
an opportunity for us to re-examine our
relationship with god individually and
as the church and our place in society
as bringers of light
amen amen
um i almost thought we'd answered all
the questions um
brother nick prouschel had asked well
the first question he asked is um are we
allowed to take a shower on sabbath
okay
are we allowed to take a shower on
sabbath
when i came into the african church that
was a debate and i had a friend who
never showered on south i mean when he
was fine i mean you you can't smell that
badly just friday at 7. he was just he
took a shower on friday and that was it
until the sunset
taking a shower in the days of ellen
white particularly in the winter was
quite a chore so i'm told getting wood
warming up the water doing all that
stuff that's not the case today you can
take a shower in three minutes
and so a shower on sabbath is nowhere
condemned by the church
it's a personal choice
you want to shower ensemble shower and
sound
you don't want to please shower on
friday
because it's a matter of hiding and
cleanliness and that's a very biblical
requirement but showering on sabbath is
not regarded by the church as a crime
nor does the bible present it as a crime
so you want to share on sabbath do that
now there's some things we should do
before sabbath
get our clothes together shine our shoes
do all of that before the sabbath
but a shower and sabbath
is not a sin
amen amen
um brother nick also asked how he can
donate to your ministry
so if you can put that information in
the chat elder skeet
no i'll give you you can give it to him
okay so i'll do that i'll do that oh
definitely make sure he is people ask me
that sometimes and i write back i tell
them in capitalized world make sure you
are convicted
if you're not don't do it i tell them
that all this time make sure you are
convicted
if you cannot say you're convicted god
bless you don't do it
but i'll give you the information you
can give it to him god bless him for
even thinking like that
amen amen
now i know we have other questions that
came in but it's almost 3 30. so we have
noted your questions and there will be
acts god willing next month september 25
how many are they
how many are they let me see i see
uh
one
okay let's take that one and pull it off
okay
oh boy
first let's pray father as we close off
with the final question continue to give
us wisdom i pray in jesus name amen
amen amen
all right so
i'll i'll take sister amoy brenda's
question
hello pastor
in reference to galatians five
yes paul tells them not to be slaves to
the law
does this mean that all the laws in
deuteronomy 5 are no longer binding
today
i wish he caught the first where paul
says do not be a slave to the law where
does paul say that
she said galatians 5 let me quickly flip
and see
okay
you know i
i i'm i'm not seeing it right away the
first the first verse say stand fast
therefore in the liberty wherewith
christ hath made us free be entangled
again with the yoke of bondage
um
verse 4 christ has become of no effect
unto you whosoever of you are justified
by the law
fallen from grace
yes
that doesn't say that you're slave to
the law only christ can justify you the
law is not an instrument of
justification the law is the standard of
righteous living
christ alone can justify but the fact
that christ justifies does not cancel
the law because justification the
evidence that a man or woman is truly
justified and sanctified and saved is by
his or her conformity with god's law
and so christ justifies you and he tells
you you live according to that standard
which is the righteousness of christ as
expressed in the law so a justified
person
that conversion is verified by the law
you remove the law there's no way of
telling the person is truly justified
converted sanctified or anything of that
kind the law is not something to be
truly a slave the law is a living
principle that expresses a very
righteousness of jesus christ it is a
lifestyle expected of someone who is
converted
we're not the slave law
you know and then jesus it's the son of
christ i delight to do thy will oh my
god yea thy lord is in my heart
something in the heart is done gladly
not slavishly gladly
so there's no such thing as slave to the
law you may be a slave to a ceremonial
law you're not a slave to god's moral
law
it's a lifestyle
and it's central the spinal cord of the
10 commandments is love not slavery
amen i don't know where the sister got
the teaching there paul says we're
slaves to the law but if we are it's not
the ten commandments
all right oh they're skeet i'm so sorry
but someone is is begging me to ask
okay all right so this question comes
from sister cassandra james who says i
am a person with numerous underlying
health conditions okay i'm forced to
take the vaccine against my wishes will
god hold it against me you cannot be
forced to take a vaccine against your
wishes you have to choose to take it
you cannot be forced to break the
sabbath you cannot be forced to marry
outside the church you cannot be forced
to do anything
you have to decide now you may just if
your employment is threatened you may
call that i am forced nor you're not
forced you have to choose we must never
surrender the right to choose now if you
choose to take it what's that how does
that question end
will god hold it against me
i don't see how or why god will hold it
against you
i just don't
and i'm not moses i'm not but i don't
see how god can hold that against you
unless god has convicted you not to do
it if he convicts you not to do it and
you do it then you're wrong
amen amen
yes
no no i i don't want to cut you off so
i'm going to let you finish your
statement no i was about to say if you
know if you are
if you take some medication maybe you
have cancer and you take what's that
thing called for cancer patients uh that
terrible thing oh chemotherapy yeah that
ruins your your immune system
will god punish you for that who thinks
like that
it's a choice you make
or you take some statin drug it's a
choice you make so if you if you choose
the vaccine and i don't speak for or
against you if you choose it
in connection with your god you speak to
him lord what should i do psalm 32 verse
8 i will instruct me and teach thee and
wherever thou shall go you make that
choice why should god be angry with you
amen
well elder skeet we say thank you thank
you thank you for your sacrifice of time
thank you for spending this over an hour
and
a half with us to answer these questions
we do not take the sacrifice of time
lightly and we pray that the spirit of
the living god will continue to rest
upon you your wife and entire family and
may he go before you and continue to
order your steps in his word thank you
to the lady with all the underlying
health issues i'm not a doctor i'm not
prescribing anything i'm simply saying
that the number one health law is
confession of sin
it does not negate going to the doctor
taking whatever he suggests i i'm not
negating that i'm simply saying from a
spiritual perspective the number one
health law is confession of sin in a
healthful living page 433 paragraph
seven ella white writes
the consciousness of right doing is the
best medicine for disease bodies and
mind he who is at peace with god has
secured the most important requisite to
health so i'm suggesting to the lady and
anyone suffering from a variety of
diseases make sure you're right with god
at the spiritual level first
yes your doctor see your nurse your
psychiatrist your surgeons whoever but
the fundamental cost of sickness is sin
not necessarily sin you have committed
but living the sinful world and so
health law number one must be confession
of sin
not just fresh air confession of sin
that's health law number one because
when sins go a lot of things go with it
so again i'm not denying the need for a
doctor a nurse or whatever plastic
surgeon all i am saying from a spiritual
standpoint because if you read exodus 15
26 if that will diligently hearten under
the voice of the lord by god and we'll
do that which is right in this site in
other words obedience in that verse i
will put none of these diseases upon you
obedience to god
oh pete and his laws are the 10
commandments of the health laws are the
foundation of the house for life so my
dear sister who has all these conditions
make sure you're right with god make
sure you write with him and then present
your case to him
yes a righteous person can get sick yes
but sickness is never god's will so all
i'm saying is
in in addition to everything else you do
conventionally
make sure that spiritually all is right
that's all i'm saying
and that's all i have to say now and
thank you dr mccrichen for your kindness
and allowing me to continue to be a part
of this blessed blessed experience and
for those who listen god bless you and
if there's someone listening who's not a
seventh adventist but you've been
interested you've been associating make
a decision to join this church its
teachings are biblical
make a decision to keep the center of
their sabbath it does not save you it
demonstrates your surrender to god or
your willingness to do whatever he says
make a decision to follow truth you will
never regret it that's my appeals anyone
listening who is not a 70 advertiser and
for someone listening who's backslidden
come back
come back while the door of mercy is
open come back today right where you are
make a decision to come back to god
right where you are and god bless you as
you make that decision under the moving
of the spirit of god let me offer prayer
for you right now father in heaven
there's someone listening to me who
needs to accept this type of truth move
upon that man that woman that young boy
that young girl to make that decision
father there's some backslidden
adventist who needs to come back and has
been thinking of coming back father let
the spirit gently nudge the person
across that line and make that choice
while the door of mercy is still open
bless everyone who listened bless dr
mccurchion day god and their family
bless your studies keep us faithful save
us when you come until then keep us
stubbornly faithful in jesus name we
pray amen
amen and amen thank you so much
thank you so much thank you so much
other skeet for that prayer for that
appeal in fact i had written up appeal i
don't even have to to say it anymore
um so praise god for that
thank you for your time you're welcome
we will now have an appeal song by
brother kevin gomez and friends as you
listen to the words of this song really
meditate on them
and allow jesus into
your hearts
brother kevin gomez
let me minister thank you
[Music]
so
i thought i did was right
i thought i had the answers
i thought i chose
the shortest road
but the road brought me
here
so i put on a fight
and told you how to help me
now when i have just given up
the truth
is
better than i
you
know
the way
i
let go
the need to know why
for you know
better
than
if this has been a test
i may not see the reason
but maybe knowing
i don't know it's part of getting true
i try to do what's best
and faith has made it easy
to see the best thing
i can do is put my trust in you
cause you
[Music]
know the way
[Applause]
[Music]
i've let go
let me to know
why you
know
better
[Music]
if i let you reach me
oh
[Music]
i'll take
what answers
you
supply
because you know
better
than
[Music]
praise the lord praise the lord what a
fitting beautifully ministered selection
brother gomez friends god indeed knows
better than us but we've got to trust
him
thank you so much for delivering that
peace and friends i also want you to
know that earlier
this week i i contacted brother gomez
and he actually was recovering from an
illness but god took him through and he
was able to minister this song today
friends if the lord is working upon your
heart
hearken unto him hearken unto him today
while the doors of salvation
are open
sister stacy anne
so we thank god for his
gift this gift of time
the means of salvation
and the ability to choose him
god has made this session possible and
we give him the glory for the great
things he has and will continue doing
once again elder skeet we express
appreciation to you for your sacrifice
of time for preparing for the session
spending these moments with us and
answering the questions and giving so
freely of your time
even as christ did
thank you brother jonathan david archie
for assisting me in asking the questions
thank you brother kevin gomez for
ministering in song and sister stacy
anne thank you in advance for the
closing prayer
thank you also cousin arrow for handling
much of the technological portion of
this program thank you mom for your
prayers support and words of counsel and
to all of you that have tuned in today
shared commented acts to your questions
and subscribed thank you
and we hope to see you again
sabbath september 25 at 2 o'clock p.m
eastern standard time as we have another
q a with elder randy skeet on the
investigative judgment
i pray we are all drawn closer to the
lord
and let our prayer be search me o god
and know my heart
try me and know my thoughts
and see if there be any wicked way in me
and lead me in the way everlasting
that's psalm 139 verses 23 and 24
sister stacy anne will now do the
closing prayer
happy sabbat everyone let us pray
dear heavenly merciful father we thank
you so much for this opportunity for you
have
given us the great bread to search the
scripture and to see your presence
help us lord god to not take lightly
anything that was said today
but help us dear lord to examine
ourselves
help us dear lord to
walk to realize whether we have been
walking in the way
or if we have not
and lord if we have not been sent
help us to see her our true conditions
and to run to you lord god
thank you for the promise that you give
us
when we turn to you and we confess our
sins and when we acknowledge our need
for our savior
bless us even now theresa as we go our
separate ways
and bring us back again
next month
to grow
more
in the knowledge of the truth
thank you again for sister denisha and
all those that and pastor east
and all those that have made this
program what it is and those that have
posted their questions here wrong
every brother sister brother and sister
in this group this uh this program today
bless them so much
so that they know without a doubt that
you are their god and they are your
people
thank you again we pray in jesus name
amen and amen
amen and amen thank you so much sister
stacy anne and thank you all may the
lord bless you and keep you in jesus
name we pray amen